This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. All countries have national myths. Here in the United States, thanksgiving evokes the warm glow of intercultural contact. European settlers were struggling to make it in the new world, and Native American tribes were eager to help. If we were to think a little more deeply and a little more critically, we might remember other stories from history classes. These are tales of exclusion and expulsion of Native American tribes pushed out from
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。所有国家都有自己的民族神话。在美国，感恩节唤起了不同文化接触时的温馨氛围。欧洲定居者当时正在新世界艰难求生，而美洲原住民部落则热心地提供帮助。如果我们进行更深入、更具批判性的思考，我们可能会想起历史课上的其他故事。这些故事讲述了原住民部落遭受排挤和驱逐，随着定居者对这片大陆的殖民，他们被赶出了
their homelands as settlers colonized the continent. But there's a third story you might not have heard. Many Native Americans came to know the settlers, not through happy thanks-givings, or even through war and colonization, but through slavery. We say that there have been 12.5 million Africans forcibly transported across the Atlantic as slaves into the new world. That is a very powerful thing to say.
自己的家园。但还有一个你可能没听过的第三个故事。许多美洲原住民认识定居者，不是通过快乐的感恩节，甚至不是通过战争和殖民，而是通过奴隶制。我们常说，曾有 1250 万非洲人作为奴隶被强行运送跨越大西洋来到新世界。这是一个非常有冲击力的数字。
And I wanted to get a rough sense of how Indians slavery compared to that. So I came up with a figure of 2.5 to 5 million Native Americans enslaved throughout the Americas since Columbus to 1900. 2.5 to 5 million people. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore this hidden history and the psychological reasons
我当时想粗略了解一下印第安人奴隶制与此相比情况如何。因此我得出这样一个数字：自哥伦布发现美洲到 1900 年期间，整个美洲共有 250 万至 500 万美洲原住民被奴役。250 万到 500 万人。本周的 Hidden Brain，我们将探讨这段被掩盖的历史，以及它
it's remained submerged for so long. Andres Resendés is a history professor at the University of California, Davis. He is the author of the other slavery, the uncovered story of Indian enslavement in America. Andres, welcome to Hidden Brain. It is a pleasure to be here. Thank you so much for having me. I want to begin by having you paint a picture for us.
长期隐匿背后的心理原因。安德烈斯·雷森德斯（Andres Resendés）是加州大学戴维斯分校的历史学教授。他是《另一种奴隶制：美洲印第安人被奴役的不为人知的故事》一书的作者。安德烈斯，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。很高兴能来到这里。非常感谢邀请我。我想先请你为我们描绘一幅画面。
And I want to start in 1495, when Christopher Columbus sends five ships back to Spain from the New World. On board are 550 captives, mostly from the Caribbean. Who are these people and where is Columbus sending them? Well, Columbus has mounting problems because the riches that he thought he would find in the lands of Asia where he was hoping to go were non-materializing. And in the meantime, the costs of sending more fleets to the new world were mounting.
我想从 1495 年开始说起，当时克里斯托弗·哥伦布从新世界派出了五艘船返回西班牙。船上载有 550 名俘虏，大多来自加勒比地区。这些人是谁？哥伦布要把他们送到哪里去？嗯，哥伦布面临的问题越来越多，因为他原以为在亚洲——他本希望去的地方——能找到的财富并没有兑现。与此同时，派遣更多船队前往新世界的成本却在不断增加。
And so he decided that one good way to pay for these costs was by sending some Indians back to the slave markets of the Mediterranean in this case in particular to Spain. And they selected out of close to a thousand Native Americans, the best ones, crammed them into these ships and shipped them back to the old world. Besides the idea that the slave trade was part of a business model, there were also other elements of it. You cite a letter that one of Columbus's childhood friend sends that reveals another aspect of how this famous explorer viewed the slave trade. What was in that letter?
因此他决定，支付这些成本的一个好办法就是把一些印第安人送回地中海的奴隶市场，在这个案例中特别是送到西班牙。他们从将近一万名美洲原住民中挑选出最好的人选，把他们塞进这些船里，然后运回旧世界。除了将奴隶贸易视为商业模式的一部分之外，其中还有其他因素。你引用了哥伦布的一位童年朋友写的一位信件，它揭示了这位著名探险家看待奴隶制的另一个侧面。那封信里写了什么？
Well, this is a letter by a childhood friend, Michele Dacuneo, an Italian fellow genoese, who traveled with these indigenous slaves bound for Europe. And Columbus had actually given his friend a young Native American woman as a gift. And Cuneo is very explicit about the fact that in seeing her naked, he wanted to have sex with her. It reveals the very terrible fact that the vast majority of these conquistadors were males and many of the indigenous victims ended up being both women and children. And so this is one instance of that. You mentioned something in the book that I found surprising when I first read it, which is that women and children were often valued more highly as slaves than were men.
嗯，这是一封由他的童年朋友米歇尔·达库内奥（Michele Dacuneo）写信的信，他是一个热那亚人，和这些开往欧洲的本土奴隶一起旅行。哥伦布实际上送给了他的朋友一个年轻的美洲原住民女性作为礼物。库内奥非常直白地描述了这样一个事实：在看到她赤身裸体时，他想和她发生性关系。这揭示了一个非常残酷的事实，即绝大多数这些征服者都是男性，许多本土受害者最终既是女性又是儿童。所以这是其中的一个例证。你在书中提到了我初读时觉得很惊讶的一点，那就是女性和儿童作为奴隶的价值往往比男性更高。
Is sexual slavery part of what explains that? It is surely one aspect of it. The price differential that you are referring to was very surprising to me when I discovered that because in some instances it could be that women were worth 50 or even 60% more than adult males. So the scale was generally adult women were the highest valued slaves followed by girls followed by boys and followed by grown men and there was a big drop-off for the adult males. Maybe you can think about it as the antecedent of modern-day forms of sex trafficking. That was certainly a part of it. Another part of it had to do with women's reproductive capabilities. So they could produce yet more slaves.
性奴隶制是解释这一现象的原因之一吗？这当然是其中的一个方面。你所说的价格差异在我发现时让我感到非常惊讶，因为在某些情况下，女性的价值可能比成年男性高出 50% 甚至 60%。所以总体的价格层级是：成年女性是价值最高的奴隶，其次是女孩，然后是男孩，最后是成年男子，而成年男性的价格则大幅下降。也许你可以把它看作是现代性贩运形式的前身。这当然是其中的一部分。另一部分与女性的生育能力有关。因此她们可以生出更多的奴隶。
So that was another factor. Children were especially versatile because they could learn languages more easily than adults. They could, even in the fullness of time, identify with their captors. So masters were especially keen on having children. Contrary to what we might think, slavery in America did not begin with Columbus or other European conquerors. The roots of slavery run much deeper. But the large scale operations that Europeans put in place dramatically increase the scale and the scope of the practice.
所以这是另一个因素。儿童尤其具有多变性，因为他们比成年人更容易学习语言。随着时间的推移，他们甚至会认同他们的俘虏者。因此主人特别热衷于拥有儿童。与我们的想法相反，美洲的奴隶制并不是始于哥伦布或其他欧洲征服者。奴隶制的根源要深得多。但欧洲人建立的大规模行动极大地增加了这一做法的规模和范围。
We really don't know when slavery began. In the new world, probably from the very beginning of the occupation of the continent, what we do know is that there is plenty of archaeological and pictorial evidence, as well as some of the early chronicles of the New World, depict the enslavement of natives prior to the arrival of Europeans. In the Eastern Seaboard of the United States,
我们确实不知道奴隶制是什么时候开始的。在新世界，这可能从这块大陆被占领之初就开始了。我们所知道的是，有大量的考古和图像证据，以及一些关于新世界早期编年史，描绘了欧洲人到来之前对原住民的奴役。在美国东海岸，
it requires people's waged wars on neighboring groups for the purpose of avenging their dead and replacing them with captives in the Pacific Northwest. Elite marriages were often sealed by providing slaves. So we know that these activities went on, and they were, however, a very bound in specific cultural context. And so what changed with the arrival of the Europeans was that these culturally bound activities became commodified and expanded in scale until becoming something closer to what we would recognize as modern day human trafficking.
这需要人们为了报复死者并用俘虏取而代之，而对邻近群体发动战争；而在太平洋西北地区，精英阶层的联姻通常是通过提供奴隶来确立的。所以我们知道这些活动一直在进行，然而它们被非常严格地限制在特定的文化语境中。因此，随着欧洲人的到来，发生改变的是这些受文化限制的活动被商品化了，并且在规模上不断扩大，最终变得更接近我们今天所认识的现代人口贩运。
You mentioned that by the 19th century, Brigham Young, one of the early leaders of the Mormon church and the founder of Sochlik City, he has to decide whether Mormons can buy and sell slaves. What does he do? When the Mormons arrived in Utah, they found that the entire region had already been turned into slaving ground by natives themselves and by Hispanic children who were tortured or kept outside in very cold conditions as a tactic to force Mormons to acquire these Indians. And by 1850 or 1851, young and other leaders, Mormon leaders decide that the best way to deal with this situation is to actually their term was to buy these Indians into freedom. Eventually, groups like the
你提到，到了 19 世纪，盐湖城（Salt Lake City）的建立者、摩门教早期领袖之一杨百翰（Brigham Young），必须决定摩门教徒是否可以买卖奴隶。他做了什么？当摩门教徒抵达犹他州时，他们发现整个地区已经被原住民自己以及西班牙裔儿童变成了奴隶狩猎场。这些儿童遭受折磨或被关在非常寒冷的户外，以此作为逼迫摩门教徒收留这些印第安人的战术。到了 1850 年或 1851 年，杨和其他摩门教领袖决定，应对这种情况的最佳方法其实是——用他们的话说——出资将这些印第安人买至自由。最终，像
Mormons found ways to rationalize their beliefs in slavery and to reconcile it in some ways with the mission of the church. And of course, this has parallels with other ideas and ideologies that you describe in the book. European settlers and colonists apparently had long-linked character with latitude and they used this as a justification for slavery. That's right. So these are very ancient beliefs about the character of people
摩门教这样的群体找到了合理化其对奴隶制的信仰的方法，并以某种方式将其与教会的使命调和起来。当然，这与你在书中描述的其他观点和意识形态有相似之处。欧洲定居者和殖民者显然长期将人的性格与纬度联系在一起，并以此作为奴隶制的正当理由。没错。所以这些是非常古老的关于人类性格的信仰，
depending on where they lived on earth. So they believe, for example, that the people who lived in the cold regions of Earth were very bold and intrepid, but they lacked intelligence. And conversely, that the people close to the equator were intelligent and therefore would make great slaves, but lacked in courage and boldness. And of course, the perfect balance of these two traits existed in the temperate areas. And by that, you have to read the European Mediterranean.
这取决于他们生活在地球上的什么地方。例如，他们认为生活在地球寒冷地区的人非常勇敢无畏，但缺乏智力。相反，靠近赤道的人很聪明，因此会成为极好的奴隶，但缺乏勇气和胆量。当然，这两种特质的完美平衡存在于温带地区。说到这里，你得理解为欧洲的地中海地区。
Regions were Spain, England, France, et cetera, existed, and had a perfect blend of these characteristics. And so that was one way to rationalize the enslavement of natives and other people in Sub-Saharan Africa for that matter. Andres has many examples that challenge how we think about slavery in America. We might think of the West Coast
也就是西班牙、英国、法国等国存在的地区，那里拥有这些特征的完美融合。因此，这是将原住民以及撒哈拉以南非洲的其他人的奴役行为合理化的一种方式。安德烈斯有许多例子，挑战了我们对美洲奴隶制的看法。我们可能会认为西海岸
as largely being uninvolved in slavery. In reality, the gold rush ignited a need for labor, and enslaved Native Americans were brought into meat. Two brothers who set up a cattle and mining operation north of what is today San Francisco were especially sadistic owners. Sometimes, they used slaves for target practice. During the Civil War, Union soldiers stationed in New Mexico used systematic violence to address what the federal government saw as a law and order issue, the so-called Indian problem. The method to solve this problem was to essentially relocate the entire Navajo nation
在很大程度上没有卷入奴隶制。实际上，淘金热激发了对劳动力的需求，被奴役的美洲原住民被带到这里满足需求。在今天旧金山以北建立养牛和采矿业务的两兄弟是极其残忍的主人。有时，他们把奴隶当作靶子来练习射击。内战期间，驻扎在新墨西哥州的联邦士兵使用系统性暴力来解决联邦政府视为法律与秩序问题的事情，即所谓的“印第安人问题”。解决这个问题的办法基本上是将整个纳瓦罗（Navajo）民族
from Western New Mexico to Eastern New Mexico, in what was known as the Long Walk. And this process essentially put a very large population in very vulnerable situation. Andres describes the work of an investigative journalist, John Kenneth Turner. He uncovered many of the ways that plantation owners worked around the ban on slavery well into the 20th century. And he went to the Yucatan Peninsula, posing as an American investor. And so Turner had access to these plantations, was able to look at this. Slavery was completely forbidden in Mexico at that time, but he was able to gain the confidence
从新墨西哥州西部迁移到新墨西哥州东部，这就是所谓的“漫长步行”（Long Walk）。这个过程基本上把一个非常庞大的人口置于极其脆弱的境地。安德烈斯描述了一位调查记者约翰·肯尼斯·特纳（John Kenneth Turner）的工作。他揭露了种植园主在 20 世纪很长一段时间里规避禁止奴隶制禁令的许多方法。他前往尤卡坦半岛，伪装成美国投资者。因此特纳得以进入这些种植园，并得以一探究竟。当时墨西哥完全禁止奴隶制，但他能够赢得
of these owners who said, well, you know, we know that Indian slavery is prohibited, but we have a way to get around this problem, which is that these Indians are indebted to us. And as long as there's a debt, they are unable to leave the premises, the plantations. And you could buy them in the market. And the way the planters rationalize this is that you're not really buying the person, but you are buying the debt, and the person goes with the debt. Many people over many generations helped enable the vast scale of enslavement of indigenous people. So why are the only scattered records of this history in our textbooks and public consciousness?
这些种植园主的信任，他们说：“嗯，你知道的，我们知道印第安人奴隶制是被禁止的，但我们有一个解决这个问题的办法，那就是这些印第安人欠我们的债。只要有债务，他们就无法离开这些场所，即种植园。而且你可以在市场上买下他们。”种植园主将此合理化为：你其实不是在买这个人，而是在买这笔债，而这个人是跟债务一起转手的。许多人在数代人的时间里，共同促成了对原住民的大规模奴役。那么，为什么我们的教科书和公众意识中只有关于这段历史的零星记录呢？
Stay with us. Andres, you call your book The Other Slavery. Why do you describe the history of the enslavement of Native peoples in contrast with the experience of African slaves in the United States? Because unlike African slavery, which was legal for centuries and sanctioned by states and empires around the world, labor was very early on made illegal. Even eight years after Columbus first set foot in the new world, there were questions about the legality of the enslavement of Indians, and as early as 1542, the Spanish ground outlawed Indian slavery under all circumstances. However, because Native American labor had been essential to all of the economic activities going on during this first generation of colonialism, it was unthinkable for the European colonists
请继续收听。安德烈斯，你把你的书命名为《另一种奴隶制》。为什么你要将原住民被奴役的历史与美国非洲奴隶的经历进行对比来描述呢？因为与非洲奴隶制不同——非洲奴隶制合法存在了几个世纪，并受到世界各地国家和帝国的认可——原住民劳动力很早就被宣布为非法。甚至在哥伦布首次踏上新世界八年后，就有人对奴隶化印第安人的合法性提出了质疑；早在 1542 年，西班牙王室就在所有情况下取缔了印第安人奴隶制。然而，由于美洲原住民的劳动力对殖民主义第一代发生的所有经济活动都至关重要，欧洲殖民者根本无法想象
to do without native slaves. And so they very quickly devised all kinds of subterfuges and euphemisms in order to continue to profit from the course labor of natives by calling it different names. So I call it others slavery in the sense that not only that it target Native Americans as opposed to Africans, but also in the sense that it encompassed a multiplicity of institutions or labor practices that we really need to put together and understand together if we want to gain a sense of the scope of these others' labor, yes, I call it. So, I think the point that you're trying to make is that slavery in some ways is an adaptable concept. So, in some cases, people, people of course are chained and tortured,
没有原住民奴隶的日子。因此，他们非常迅速地设计出各种遁词和委婉说法，通过换用不同的名称来继续从原住民的强迫劳动力中牟取暴利。所以我称之为“另一种奴隶制”，不仅因为它以美洲原住民为目标而非非洲人，还因为它包含多种多样的制度或劳动力实践，如果我们想了解这些“其他”劳动力的范围，我们就必须把它们放在一起并共同理解。是的，我称之为“另一种奴隶制”。所以，我认为你想表达的观点是，奴隶制在某种程度上是一个可适应的概念。因此，在某些情况下，人们、人们当然会被戴上镣铐和折磨，
but in other cases, coercion can take on different forms. At the same time, it's obviously important to distinguish between somebody who's enslaved and somebody who's working in, for example, just difficult labor conditions. In the way that you have gone about your study, how are you defining who constitutes a slave? These definitional problems came from the very beginning of the project.
但在其他情况下，强迫可以采取不同的形式。与此同时，显然重要的是，要区分被奴役的人和例如在艰难劳动条件下工作的人。在你开展研究的过程中，你如何定义谁构成奴隶？这些定义上的问题从这个项目一开始就出现了。
So I came up with a list of four characteristics that made these other slavery fit the bill of what I call slavery. And so one of them was that natives usually were forcibly moved far away from their place of origin. And this may not have occurred at the very beginning, but very quickly, the owners came to realize that enslaving natives who lived very close to them could open themselves to retaliation. And so the way to do it was to send them to far away places. So displacement to far away places was one of the characteristics that I early on realized
所以我列出了四个特征，使这种“另一种奴隶制”符合我所谓的奴隶制的标准。其中之一是，原住民通常被强行移居到远离其原籍地的地方。这可能在刚开始时没有发生，但很快，主人就意识到，奴隶化那些离他们很近的原住民可能会招致报复。因此，这样做的方法是把他们送到遥远的地方。所以，流放到遥远的地方是我很早就意识到的一大特征。
was common to many of these labor practices. Second of all, they were unable to leave their place of work, whether you were talking about indebted workers or people serving out their sentences or people entrusted, etc. They could not willingly leave their place of work. Third characteristic was the use of violence or at least the threat of use of violence in order to seek compliance. And finally, there was the question of payment, which was often non-existent, or if it existed it was so low that it was practically symbolic. One of the ideas in Andres' book has less to do with history and more to do with psychology.
这是许多此类劳动力实践所共有的。其次，他们无法离开工作场所，无论你谈论的是负债工人、服刑人员还是被委托人员等。他们不能自愿离开工作场所。第三个特征是使用暴力或至少是使用暴力的威胁，以寻求服从。最后是报酬问题，报酬往往不存在，或者如果存在，也是如此之低，以至于实际上只具有象征意义。安德烈斯书中的观点之一与历史关系较小，而与心理学关系更大。
It has to do with how our minds tend to categorize historical events. When I talk about enslaved people in America, you might think of people brought over from Africa. But if I talk about Native Americans, you're more likely to think of dispossession and exclusion. We are so focused on these categories that have been drilled into us from childhood that we seem unable to escape our historical myopia, as I call it, in the book. And this is especially difficult to break
这与我们的头脑倾向于如何将历史事件分类有关。当我谈到美洲的被奴役人口时，你可能会想到从非洲运来的人。但如果我谈到美洲原住民，你更有可能想到的是被剥夺财产和排挤。我们太专注于这些从小就被灌输给我们的分类，以至于我们似乎无法摆脱历史的近视，正如我在书中称之的那样。而在美洲原住民的情况下，这一点尤其难以打破，
in the case of Native Americans because, as I have explained, this was not a legal institution and it was not a single institution, but it was a multiplicity of labor practices. And so that has conspired to prevent us from realizing both the scale and even the very existence of these others' labor. One of the things that put your work into context for me is that you pointed out that West Africa saw a population decline of about 20% as a result of slavery and of course a scale of that is just is just incomprehensible. Indigenous people in the New World also suffered catastrophic declines in population as a result of slavery. Could you talk about that for a second?
因为正如我所解释的，这不是一个合法的制度，也不是一个单一的制度，而是一种多重劳动力实践的组合。因此，这导致我们既无法意识到这些“其他”劳动力的规模，甚至无法意识到它们的存在本身。使你的工作对我产生启发的一点是，你指出西非由于奴隶制而经历了大约 20% 的人口下降，当然，这种规模简直是不可理解的。新世界的原住民也因奴隶制而遭受了灾难性的人口下降。你能谈谈这个吗？
I don't want to make this into a race to the bottom. I mean, both Africans and Native Americans lost immasherably as a result of these nexus of epidemics and enslavement. And I can talk about that relationship. But the point that I make is that in the case of Native Americans, especially in the Caribbean and some regions in the Gulf of Mexico, the level of decimation was staggering. I mean, it was much greater than 20%, it could be 80%, 90%. So it is good to bear in mind the staggering numbers. What is the relationship between enslavement and the spread of epidemics and infection?
我不想把这变成一场谁更惨的比赛。我的意思是，非洲人和美洲原住民都因为这盘根错节的流行病和奴隶制而蒙受了无可估量的损失。我可以谈谈这种关系。但我的观点是，就美洲原住民而言，特别是在加勒比地区和墨西哥湾的一些地区，被毁灭的程度是惊人的。我的意思是，它远大于 20%，可能是 80%、90%。所以牢记这些惊人的数字是很好的。奴隶制与流行病和传染病的传播之间有什么关系？
It's one of synergy, but what I found in the case of the Caribbean is that epidemic disease essentially reduced the number of slaves, which prompted slavers to launch raids into other islands. And the launching of these raids in turn spread epidemic disease. So it was a complete reinforcing circle that resulted in great devastation in the case of the Caribbean. We have thanksgiving coming up in the United States. And of course, it's an occasion where we express gratitude and thanks to one another but it's also a moment of historical reflection and we give thanks in some ways for native peoples who helped the early settlers through a very difficult winter. I'm wondering as you
这是一种协同作用，但在加勒比地区，我发现流行病基本上减少了奴隶的数量，这促使奴隶贩子向其他岛屿发动袭击。而发动这些袭击反过来又传播了流行病。所以这是一个完全相互强化的循环，在加勒比地区造成了巨大的破坏。美国的感恩节就要到了。当然，这是一个我们向彼此表达感激和谢意的节日，但它也是一个进行历史反思的时刻，我们在某种程度上感谢那些在极其艰难的冬天帮助早期定居者的原住民。我想知道，当你带着你所知道的历史
sit down at Thanksgiving knowing the history that you do, how do you how do you see Thanksgiving? Have you come to think of it differently? Well, I have come to think of the the whole early colonial period of the Americas differently as a result of this book. I have gained a new found appreciation for the the difficulty of surviving in this tough environment, the ruthlessness with which all human groups pursued these goals and were willing to avail themselves to other humans in order to achieve their goals. As I said, this is not a history of good people and bad people. I did find some indigenous groups who did not take captives or slaves.
坐在感恩节的餐桌旁时，你是如何看待感恩节的？你对它的看法有所改变吗？嗯，由于这本书，我对美洲整个早期殖民时期有了不同的看法。我对在如此恶劣环境中生存的艰难有了新的体会，也体会到了所有人类群体在追求这些目标时表现出的冷酷无情，以及为了实现目标而愿意利用其他人类的倾向。正如我所说，这不是一个关于好人和坏人的历史。我确实发现了一些没有抓捕俘虏或奴隶的原住民群体。
Oftentimes because they were too small or because of environmental reasons, it made no sense to acquire more people because they would also mean more mouths to feed. But other than that, I found that everybody who was in a position to do it and profit from it did it. And in some ways, it's a difficult book to write because in the final part of the book, I mentioned that these forms of enslavement were not very dissimilar to the forms that we now call modern forms of enslavement, we're not very dissimilar to the forms that we now call modern forms of enslavement. In the sense that slavery is today prohibited all over the world, yet some over 45 million people, according to the latest estimates of the Walk Free Foundation,
通常是因为他们规模太小，或者由于环境原因，获取更多人是没有意义的，因为那也意味着要养活更多张嘴。但除此之外，我发现所有有能力做到这一点并从中获利的人都这样做了。从某种程度上说，这是一本很难写的书，因为在书的最后部分，我提到这些形式的奴隶制与我们现在所称的现代奴隶制形式并没有太大区别，这些形式与我们现在所称的现代奴隶制形式并没有太大区别。在这个世界上到处都禁止奴隶制的今天，然而根据“自由行走基金会”（Walk Free Foundation）的最新估计，仍有 4500 多万人
are in a condition of modern day enslavement. And the ways in which these people are enslaved are in some ways reminiscent of what Native Americans experience for a period of 400 years. Andres Rosandez is a history professor at the University of California Davis. He is the author of the other slavery, the Uncovered Story of Indian Enslavement in America. Andres, thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Pennman and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Tara Boyle, René Clarre, Parth Shah and Jenny Schmidt. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram.
处于现代奴隶制的状态。而这些人被奴役的方式，在某种程度上让人想起美洲原住民经历了 400 年的遭遇。安德烈斯·罗萨恩德斯（Andres Rosandez）是加州大学戴维斯分校的历史学教授。他是《另一种奴隶制：美洲印第安人被奴役的不为人知的故事》一书的作者。安德烈斯，谢谢你今天做客 Hidden Brain。非常感谢邀请我。本期 Hidden Brain 由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Pennman）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）制作。我们的团队成员包括塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）、勒内·克拉雷（René Clarre）、帕特·沙阿（Parth Shah）和珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）。要收听更多 Hidden Brain 节目，您可以在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Instagram 上关注我们。
You can hear my stories on your local public radio station on Morning Edition. Hidden Brain is also now a radio show that's airing on many stations across the United States. If you like this episode, please share it with a friend and tell us about it on social media. Our unsung hero this week is Jack McCarthy of Swansea, Massachusetts. He passed away last week, but he was a high school history teacher, a football and baseball coach, and superintendent of schools in Swansea for nearly two decades. In 1985, he made national headlines by allowing a child with AIDS to attend public school, at a time when school systems across the country were turning such children away.
您可以在当地公共广播电台的《早间新闻》（Morning Edition）节目中收听我的故事。Hidden Brain 现在也成为了一档广播节目，在美国许多电台播出。如果您喜欢本期节目，请与朋友分享，并在社交媒体上告诉我们。我们本周的无名英雄是马萨诸塞州斯旺西的杰克·麦卡锡（Jack McCarthy）。他于上周去世，曾担任近二十年的高中历史老师、足球和棒球教练，以及斯旺西的学区总监。1985 年，他允许一名患有艾滋病的儿童去公立学校上学，这一举动登上了全国各大媒体的头条，当时全国各地的学校系统都在将这样的儿童拒之门外。
In his obituary, people noted that he had strength, conviction, fortitude, courage, and Irish stubbornness. We know Jack because he was the grandfather of our own Maggie I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在他的讣告中，人们指出他具有力量、信念、坚韧、勇气和爱尔兰式的固执。我们认识杰克是因为他是我们同事玛吉的祖父。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这里是 NPR。该剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。